so this has my name etched in Gold this
is my signature piece this is what
completes an
artwork meet Eko namako a Ganan Canadian
artist making breathtaking art out of
black Lego bricks my entire life I've
probably clicked hundreds of thousands
of Parts probably Millions is it Legos
or
Lego are you serious it's Lego it's
never Legos and Lego actually is an
abbreviated form of legot which is
Danish for play well little known
fact Echo jaw-dropping sculptures are
exhibited in galleries but they began in
DIY Studios at his home welcome to
Studio A the first of My Three Studio
rooms this is where I build most of my
building black Mythos artworks really an
exploration of black African mythology
this one I'm actually not sure what this
sculpture is going to be I know it will
be a goddess I know that she will have
these kind of cornrows going on this
tubing was not made to be hair but when
I look at parts now I just see different
parts of anatomy that just like speak
out to me this artwork so far I think
I've clocked in almost 100 hours some
artworks could take up to 1,000 hours
while some of ekko's larger pieces can
take a thousand hours he can prototype a
new smaller design from scratch in just
a day so we're in Studio C is where I'm
be building my my series building black
amorphia spiritual Starships so I'm
going to build a spiritual Starship
today the idea behind it is that we are
take inspiration from science fiction
but at the same time it's very important
for me to centralize Black characters
black stories black history within that
context so I'll be taking the form of a
t47 air speeder and turning it into an
ancestral vessel so let's have some fun
all right let's see once the spine is
completed I'll look at some reference
photos of the ship and then start
constructing the wing
shape dropping Lego is actually the most
annoying thing people think that
stepping on Lego is like the most
annoying thing but to me the most
annoying thing is spilling them outright
just knocking a container over and it
just spills
everywhere
you see what I mean like the rage that
fills up when I'm just like trying to
get something done and then just
scatters well dropping pieces is a
frustration Ekko still needs to keep a
massive amount of Parts on hand to
actualize his sculptures each of my
Studios has a section that dedicated to
the parts this is Studio
B you got to love that this piece right
here is a jumper it has a stud or Notch
right in the center and opposed to a
piece like this which would naturally
have two studs on it over here I've got
various different tires the LEGO Group
actually produces the most tires in the
world more than Goodyear more than
Michelin cuz their tires are actually
made of rubber so they're classified as
actual tires oh yes the hinge with the
ball joint what this hinge joint allowed
is for me to put these fairings anywhere
I want got your standard tiles I like to
cover all the notches and studs on my
work triangle tile allows you to get
some great geometric patterns when you
put them all together these are always
great inverted tiles the beauty of
inverted Parts is that they click from
the bottom up now I do want to find like
a discontinued part like this look at
the design it's one of those pieces that
I would have to even second guess if I
saw it sitting down there and wonder if
it actually is a Lego element I think I
only have one of these in my entire
collection and I've got like millions of
Parts the most common reaction when I
tell people what I do is usually
excitement there's this kind of oh my
God you get to do what you love it is
amazing more importantly it's a
privilege you know a metric of if you
love what you do is when people say if
you won the lottery would you still do
what you do and mine would be yes I
would just get a bigger Studio more
staff and build bigger
things this piece is called cadisa
cadisa is a dragon cat and dragon cats
are creatures that I came up with I've
always been fascinated with Aven
creatures I took some inspiration from
the Griffin and made this feline cat
with wings these lengthy builds are not
just reflective of ekko's artistic
talent but also A Lifetime Love of Lego
I started building with Lego when I was
about 3 or 4 years old I started off
inheriting Lego for my older brother it
it just had this appeal to me because
you can create the things you don't have
if I see something that I wanted then I
would be able to satisfy that urge by
going to my Lego collection and building
something that would just plate me so
when I first started building it was
purely for fun eventually it got
elevated to an art form in 2007 though
is when I had this Resurgence of
interest in building and I just realized
how fun it was again and it just kind of
stayed with me a little bit closer from
that point and then by 2012 2013 I was
really trying to make my mark as an
artist and the two things just kind of
came together this artwork is very
special to me because I've had this
artwork since I began my career I
created this artwork when she was about
the size of a six-year-old since then it
has evolved what I most enjoy about this
artwork is the hair like this
cylindrical piece is great hole in the
top hole in the bottom and they have
weight that when you have so much volume
of hair there's just like a gravity to
it and when it comes to black people our
hair is political for all the people
that are going to see see this work and
be inspired by it to have their identity
reinforced from a material that
historically underrepresented them means
a lot so making the formal outlines and
the shape of a mask is like the first
step and then once the shape is laid out
then all the fun stuff really starts
happening where you get to like start
giving it some kind of personality it
can be grueling work sometimes and you
know my joints have suffered from
building carpal tunnel syndrome is real
but all the pain is worth it for Echo to
make these textured works of art this
sculpture is called quu and nany quu and
nany is an Aon deity a trickster God my
favorite feature I really like the crown
the main center part of the crown is a
combination of two different parts and
they're both discontinued if I'm not
mistaken I always think it's really
fascinating when I'm able to use
discontinued Parts because there's
something more rare about it there's
only so many of them left on the world
Nancy took me I'd say about 300 hours
plus over like a long period of time so
start thinking about the eyes when it
comes to expression yeah there's
something about the personality that can
be found in our eyes so there's
something here this eye outline looks
animated to me okay so we've got this
pair of eyes and I also did like some
structural stuff so that I can place a
nose in there right now just laying down
some tiles tiles are great because you
can put something down on the tiles and
then and like kind of slide it and shift
it so you know exactly where you want it
to sit and then once you do you start
building things that will kind of keep
it in place I think just about there you
now as you're building along you want to
make sure that you're not just building
for filler at any point problem with
Lego building too is that you run the
risk of doing too much which is what in
my opinion 90% of people that build with
Lego they do just because you can do
something doesn't mean you should
couldn't tell you what set had these
created I don't know but when I see
these things I don't buy sets a lot I
buy parts and they speak to me not as
what they are but as what they could be
all right we're almost there one good
way to get a metric of how far I have to
go how many studs do you see just need
to add a couple more pieces on
here so this is the final piece this has
my name etched in Gold this is what
completes an artwork the last click is
always
satisfying
this piece is not titled yet usually the
titles take a little while to come to me
I like that it maintained the
aerodynamic shape of the t47 air speeder
but at the same time when you look at
this mask you don't automatically
associate it with a Star Wars vessel for
me when I look at it all I see are the
faces of my ancestors when creating
masks I have a certain kind of Freedom
that I don't typically have with the
rest of my world works because there's
no body to the face I have the freedom
to make the eyes as large as I want I
have the freedom to create these kind of
like eyebrows using these fin-like
pieces no matter how many hours Ekko
spends building these marvelous pieces
of art he's always looking to the Future
both in his work and in the Lego
Community always been a futurist
imagining liberated futures for black
people and for all people ultimately I
think the LEGO Group has gotten a lot
better in regards to how inclusive and
diverse they are but growing up it was a
completely different story the
interesting thing about the Lego verse
especially when it's rooted in like the
yellow minifigure The Simpsons taught me
you know that yellow is synonymous with
white but just like any kind of equity
work there's always more and it's a long
road but it seems like they're committed
to making the right choices as a black
artist our work is healing and is
edifying for black children to see
themselves reflected in this toy form I
think that's really important and that
keeps me waking up wanting to do this as
well is that I have been granted a gift
gifts should not go to
[Music]
waste